Speaker 1: Kerry Lake. Said while speaking
to the Log Cabin Republicans that Trump is
more amazing than her own husband. Have you
ever seen someone suck up to this degree?
Look at this clip. It's starting to be painful.
The degree to which Kari Lake is, I think,
auditioning to be Donald Trump's vice president.
Unidentified:
Of course, I want to thank the most amazing man.
Speaker 3: And I think to say my husband,
he's the.
Speaker
2: Second most amazing.
Unidentified: Thing President Donald Trump has.
One. I just. Group. Here's the thing. My husband.
Speaker 1:
Her husband can be thanked later, but really the
most amazing man in her life is Trump. Why is she
doing this? Is it career advancement? She wants
to be Trump's VP or at least Trump's VP running
mate. Even if they lose, maybe it'll get her
some attention. Sort of like Sarah Palin had
for a while after losing as John McCain's VP in
2020. Maybe. Is it personal gain like she thinks
it would help her with something about trying
to steal the election in Arizona, which she's
trying to do? Or maybe it will help her continue
to grift money to say stuff like this. My husband
is less amazing than Trump. And then, of course,
fear based politics might also apply within the
Republican Party. Is there fear of reprisal which
is causing Carrie Lake to feel pressure and to
continue the show in which she just thanks Trump
endlessly for everything? And he's so good and
he's so amazing. I don't know what the answer
is, but it's starting to get pretty cringey
and pretty painful to see. But it doesn't look
like it's going to stop any time soon and any
opportunity she gets. She will pray at the altar.
She's on her knees for Trump. Jesus, I think,
is the way we would put it. After the break, we'll
get to other elements of America Fest. We're going
to hear a new analysis from Glenn Kirschner and
so many other things. Glad you're with us. Friday,
December 23. This Friday year end membership
special. Your first month payment will be
donated to charity that helps people directly
with cash and doubled matched dollar for
dollar. Make sure you're on my mailing list for
this Friday. Sign up at David Pakman dot com.